marc sylvestre bonjour merci d'être en
direct avec nous alors ce premier jour
de déconfinement est marquée par la
réouverture des commerces ainsi que des
liberté de circuler sans autorisation
préalable
l'idée évidemment est de remettre la
france au travail ce que ce confinement
va permettre une reprise de l'activité
si oui dans combien de temps
écoutez la réponse est non on va pas
reprendre très rapidement l'activité
parce que le déconfinement va être très
progressif on l'a vu très prudent ça va
demander des semaines de quoi parce que
la situation sanitaire n'est pas
stabilisé le virus continue de circuler
on a vu et les français ne sont pas
immunisés donc nous avons encore tout à
craindre alors on les confine pas ce
qu'il faut faire repartir l'appareil
économique qui a été complètement arrêté
pendant deux mois deux mois pendant
lesquels on a demandé aux français de
rester chez eux
mais les semaines qui viennent on va
continuer de demander aux français de
rester un maximum chez eux et notamment
ceux qui sont en télétravail le col par
prendre les transports en commun
reprennent on le voit bien les centres
commerciaux vont réouvrir des grands
magasins et boutiques
mais je le répète pendant trois semaines
on va vivre au ralenti en régime fallait
dire de semi-liberté en vérifiant tout
ce qui se passe du côté du virus parce
que c'est sale indicateurs clés tout
tout ce qui se passe du côté d admission
en hôpital et si la situation ne se
dégrade pas eh bien on élargira ce
déconfinement au début de mois tu vas en
ouvrant je crois les cafés des hôtels et
restaurants et peut-être même certaines
salles de spectacles nous sommes dans un
exercice très délicat qui consiste à
faire repartir l'économie sans pour
autant réveiller le lobby
alors quelles sont précisément les
difficultés les freins auxquels on est
confrontés actuellement c'est une
évidence il ya un problème de confiance
confiance dans l'état de santé confiance
dans la situation sanitaire
et puis aussi peut-être défiance à
l'égard du gouvernement on était
confronté à une pandémie terrible 26
mille décès en france
nous savons que très peu de choses sur
ce virus nous n'avons ni traitement ni
vaccin et nous avons des risques de
pénurie aussi en salle de réanimation de
l'hôpital on a peur de manquer on a eu
peur de manquer de basques ou de tests
ces problèmes là sont en train de se
régler progressivement la peur du pauvre
19 est encore très présente
conséquence est bien la majorité des
français hésitent à reprendre le travail
ils se savent un peu benêt
c'est la responsabilité en incombe bien
sûr août et des gens position était
quand même très indécis très incertain
la responsabilité en incombe aussi aux
chefs d'entreprises qui sont pas
forcément prêts à appliquer tout de
suite tous les protocoles de sécurité
et dieu sait s'ils sont très compliquées
la responsabilité en incombe enfin aux
dirigeants de l'administration qui ne
sont peut-être pas assez préparé les
avez sans doute le temps de le faire
dans l'éducation nationale et des
transports notamment enfin les syndicats
ont eux aussi une part de responsabilité
parce que dans leur souci affiché de
protéger des salariés ils exigent des
conditions de sécurité extrêmes il ya
peut-être un peu de mauvaise foi là
dedans à vouloir retarder la date est de
faire jouer parfois le droit aux
retraites j'ajoute que vous avez décret
le juridique qui est maquillée
dirigeants à dure épreuve
un directeur d'école un maire un chef de
gare un ministre de nous mêmes un
premier ministre peut être accusé de ne
pas appliquer ces règles il peut être
accusé et sa responsabilité à ce
moment-là civile et pénale est engagée
il y à une pression de l'appareil
judiciaire avec un risque réel alors
jean marc est ce qu'on peut faire sauter
ces freins et si oui est-ce que la
reprise pourrait être rapide selon vers
la la la réponse est oui là parce qu'il
faut quand même été assez optimiste vous
vous trouverez on trouvera demain un
traitement ou un vaccin
cette épée de damoclès que le coït 19
tient disparaît et est si elle disparaît
un jour tout repart alors quand est ce
que ça peut ça peut disparaître il ya le
vaccin on nous a promis des premiers
vaccins pour la fin de l'année
le traitement je pense qu'on réussira
quand même à dégager quelques quelques
prescriptions mais nous serions
aujourd'hui peut-être nous pourrions
être dans une courbe en v une baisse
rapide suivie d'un vin d'un rebond les
appareils de production n'ont pas été
détruits on est parent après une guerre
les trains fonctionnent les les avions
les bateaux ne sont pas en panne et puis
en plus de l'argent en circulation
puisque tous les salariés au chômage
partiel ont touché ce chômage et ils
n'ont pas beaucoup dépensé cet argent
donc c'est un temps pour revenir dans le
circuit il ya des facteurs de croissance
il ya des facteurs de croissance
silvia elle serait 2e tour partant en
septembre
mais l'année 2020 sera quand même très
handicapé le restera dans l'histoire une
des années les plus catastrophe avec un
pib annuel en baisse de 10% c'est du
jamais vu
normalement devrait donc repartir fin
2020 2021 nous n'aurions pas à ce moment
là la courbe en v que tout le monde à
laquelle tout le monde rêvait un peu
mais une courbe revenus c'est-à-dire
avec une descente qui a été très rapide
on a en mars avril et puis un plafond et
puis une remontée moins rapide au début
de l'année prochaine donc reprise assez
vite parce que c'est quand même dans six
mois une reprise qui s'accompagnera de
changements structurels
alors là c'est un grand point
d'interrogation télétravail va
évidemment changer l'organisation du
travail
les échanges avec la chine seront sans
doute plus sélectif et puis les pays
européens peuvent peut-être été un peu
plus solidaire on verra ça dans quelques
mois mais on peut rêver
merci beaucoup jean marc sylvestre
journaliste et éditorialiste économique